rise of the Tomb Raider is doubling down
on skills so players can customize Lara
to their play style whether it's taking
down multiple enemies at once crafting
new weapons or learning languages
there's a lot of new abilities we
haven't seen before so we talked to game
director Brian Horton to go in-depth on
some of the new skills for adventuring
hunting and combat we broken skills down
into three separate categories in the
last game we had categories but you had
to unlock them in such a way that didn't
really give you the choice on which area
you would invest in you'd have to sort
of do them all universally now we're
giving you choices so for instance if
you're a more aggressive player the
brawler category might be great for you
and what we do is we use our skill
points which you earn in game two to
unlock certain abilities and one of our
favorite abilities is definite above the
native sets snares in the clearing
must-have plan for us to pursue
beginning of the game when you climb up
a tree you're prompted to knock a guy
out from above this is a multi-stage
process you jump down it knocks them on
the ground and you have to pick up a
rock and take them out this is both slow
and also a little bit loud not perfect
for stealth so when you achieve this
upgrade you're able to use your knife
and do a death from above in one single
shot it's more stealthy and it's a great
move to really show her escalation and
power and ability to stay silent
predator
second category is the hunter category
this helps with Lara's hunting and
scavenging abilities now one of our
favorites in this area is the double
shot this allows Lara to line up two
targets in one pull and get to reticles
that form over those targets and release
kills both targets in one shot the third
category is survivor this is crafting an
exploration so one of our favorite
skills for this is the body trap
specialist what this allows you to do is
take one of the bombs that you've
crafted assign it to one of the corpses
in the game this sends out a ping in the
world enemies will be gravitated toward
this ping as soon as they get in
proximity the poison gas will go off in
an area effect this takes out multiple
enemies in one shot it's extremely
satisfying to pull off
you hear that
there's more to our skills than just
combat centric abilities and upgrades we
also have these skills that really help
you for if you're an explorer if you
really like to collect a hundred percent
of everything in the game we have one
called I for detail and that allows you
to illuminate things challenge objects
everything in the world that you might
want to collect and gives that player an
ability to really get a hundred percent
of the items that we have to offer in
the game illuminates them gives you an
idea of where to find them so it's great
for that but ultimately Lara in her
heart is an archaeologist she's someone
who loves to explore these ancient
spaces and in doing so we wanted to
improve on some of the systems that
embrace that part of a personality and
that's where our language system came
into place there's going to be model us
all throughout the world that Lara will
have to decipher in different languages
she first encounters one that's in Greek
in the Syrian tomb and she'll be able to
decipher these by going up to murals
reading journals using that as an
ability to build her language skill and
ultimately translate these model lists
the model lists are great because once
you translate them they give you
locations all throughout the world that
you'll be able to collect things like
such as gold coins that we use later on
in the game that you'll be able to trade
for more powerful weapons or a new
outfit that the player might want to
collect so these is a really cool
economy and also just feeds into the
idea of what Lara is all about which is
being this archaeologist this person
that discovers these ancient locations
we'll have to wait until November 10th
to see how deep Lara's skill
customizations go and how much they
influence individual play style check
back with us later this week when we're
going to go in-depth on creating Lara's
character and the new worlds you'll be
exploring in her latest adventure